welcome to Carnegie Mellon online for
more multimedia from Carnegie Mellon
University visit WWE
you
the latest news has the arab emirates
buying a piece of citibank putting up
some billions of dollars that's really
not a surprise since we spend about five
hundred billion dollars a year to import
oil we were actually giving away enough
money to buy the US economy we're doing
that because we're being completely
foolish about what it is we do with
respect to oil i want to talk about that
now to talk about our policies in 2003
the price of oil was about $32 a barrel
we imported eleven point two million
barrels a day and we spent a total of
131 billion dollars that year in 2007 we
import 1.3 million barrels a day more
than that the price is now hovering in
the mid 90s and we're spending almost
five hundred billion dollars a year
this difference of three hundred billion
dollars a year is a really non-trivial
difference if we had that money back if
we'd been able to keep the price of oil
at $32 we'd have enough money to
completely get rid of the deficit of the
federal government or we could get rid
of most of our balance of payments
deficit or we could fund programs like
the state's children health initiative
program over about 500 times right that
is that we are actually giving away our
national wealth and we're doing so
foolishly by the amount of oil that we
purchase in the future if we keep on
doing what we're doing right now which
is to purchase more oil every day i
figure that by about 2010 will it be
importing thirteen and a half million
barrels a day that will cost us just
under a trillion dollars a year a
trillion dollars a year at that point i
expect that there will be a gold rush to
buy companies in the united states
indeed we may put one of our state's up
for sale at those kinds of prices
we're being absolutely foolish and we've
got to stop this our presidential
candidates are actually pandering to
voters right now when they talk about
the situation they're telling us on the
Republican side that we simply
fire and find more oil and gas on the
Democratic side they're telling us that
we need to do some things about fuel
economy standards for cars and trucks
those aren't going to get us there
we need to take more action we need to
realize the amount of mistake that we're
actually making in what it is that we do
our whole foreign policy since World War
two has been aimed toward securing a
supply of cheap oil into the United
States in doing that we've backed all
kinds of corrupt dictators we've had our
foreign policy depend completely on
those aims and we're fighting our second
war in the Persian Gulf now in order to
sustain that supply of oil this is
really crazy we are the largest importer
of oil in the world China is the second
largest importer they import half of
what it is we do if we're going to do
something about the world's supply of
oil if we're going to do something about
how much we pay we're going to have to
stop pointing fingers at China and India
and start looking in the mirror it is we
who are the determinants of our future
not China and India what we have to do
is to stop big ignorant victims we're
going to have to start realizing that
the price of oil is not $90 a barrel or
$100 a barrel it's actually more like
300 to 500 dollars a barrel if you
compare today with 2002 and we then take
a look at the amount of money that we're
spending we're buying about 6 billion
barrels of oil more a year and that
comes out to more than 400 dollars a
barrel for what it is that we're buying
we have to understand that oil costs us
a lot more than the current market price
so what are we going to do we have to
realize that oil is more expensive and
that the price of gasoline is more
expensive than what we're paying right
now rather than eking out small rises
every month every year in the price of
oil we have to understand that we want
to look forward to what the real price
of oil is and do something about it now
Europe and Japan currently priced
gasoline at about
gallon I figure that's probably about
right at seven dollars a barrel I'm
sorry seven dollars a gallon we would
start reducing our demand for oil we
wouldn't have to have Congress tell us
that we need more stringent fuel economy
standards consumers would go out and
they buy those vehicles and so we don't
have to do a lot of stuff with more
government regulation all we have to do
is have a price that justifies that if
we then have this $7 a gallon price that
is a $4 a gallon tax on gasoline what
would that do to the economy well it
would raise about five hundred billion
dollars a year in new taxes he if you
had five hundred billion dollars a year
probably what most economists would
recommend is that you get rid of the
payroll tax it is terribly regressive
and it is very harmful to the economy if
we could get rid of that we would really
boost the economy and if we got rid of
the payroll tax on the first $20,000
worth of income the poor would actually
be better off they would have more money
to spend in their lives than they'd have
to pay for the additional price of
gasoline and so by doing something
intelligent about our energy policy we
would also be something doing something
intelligent about getting our economy
out of this recession that we seem to be
going into if we now take a look at this
is one more thing that we could do and
that is currently when you buy a new car
you you're told what the fuel economy of
that car is I've got a different
suggestion why don't we put on the
sticker of the car how much that car is
going to use over its lifetime of
150,000 miles if you were buying a large
SUV that got 15 miles per gallon then
over 150,000 miles you'd have to buy
10,000 gallons of gasoline at $7 a
gallon that's $70,000 that's enough to
make you think if instead you bought a
Prius at 50 miles per gallon you'd have
to buy about 3000 gallons of gasoline
over its lifetime
the difference between those two that is
7,000 gallons at $7 a gallon it's
$49,000 that's enough to send your kid
to college right and I think that those
kinds of marketplace signals would
replace any need for regulation they
would get us to go in exactly the right
direction I have this hope this hope is
that we will begin to think seriously
about our energy policy that will begin
to do something about our imports of
petroleum and in doing that I think we
would do the best thing we can to
resolve this international terrorism
issue that faces us if we stop sending
this 500 billion dollars a year overseas
to buy oil then we would be starving the
terrorists I have this dream this dream
is that we would force Osama bin Laden
to start having bake sales in order to
finance his terrorism that's what it is
we need to do that's what the
oil-producing countries have been
telling us for a long time to do it's
time to start doing it now let's have
this gasoline tax
let's bankrupt the terrace not the USA
thanks for your attention